- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Bonjour à
tous.
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par madame Isabelle Santiago
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Isabelle Santiago:
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères.
Il ne s'est pas passé un jour
cette semaine sans que
l'Azerbaïdjan ne viole le
cessez-le-feu de novembre 2020.
Elle a ciblé des civils en Arménie
et dans le Haut-Karabakh.
Avec le blocus du corridor, le
Haut-Karabakh est devenu une
prison à ciel ouvert.
Des Arméniens, dont 30.000
enfants, risquent leur vie à
chaque instant.
Depuis six mois, ces populations
manquent de tout et peinent à
survivre.
Le gaz et l'électricité sont
coupées.
La nourriture et les médicaments
ne peuvent plus être acheminés.
L'Europe accroît ses importations
de gaz depuis l'Azerbaïdjan,
pendant ce temps.
Les crises majeures que nous
traversons ne peuvent détourner
l'attention de la crise que vit le
peuple arménien.
Il est du devoir de notre nation
d'agir.
La France doit soutenir l'adoption
d'une résolution du Conseil de
sécurité à l'ONU, visant à
rétablir la libre circulation
entre l'Arménie et le
Haut-Karabakh, et faire respecter
l'accord tripartite du 9 novembre
2020.
Il convient de demander la mise en
place d'une force et de donner les
moyens à l'Arménie de se défendre.
Le 3 novembre 1896, Jean Jaurès
dénonçait le prélude du génocide
des Arméniens.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci.
Merci de votre question, madame la
députée.
Elle m'offre l'opportunité de
rappeler qu'aucun pays ne fait
autant que le nôtre en vue d'un
accord de paix entre l'Arménie et
son voisin.
Je le redis: aucun pays ne se
trouve à ses côtés autant que nous
le sommes.
Nous souhaitons une paix juste.
La France l'a encore démontré
quand le président de la
République s'est mobilisé le 1er
juin, en marge du sommet de la
Communauté politique européenne.
Il a réuni le Premier ministre et
le président de part et d'autre.
Une nouvelle réunion va avoir lieu
à Bruxelles le 21 juillet.
Il y a aussi les efforts de
coopération des Américains.
Nous sommes aussi aux côtés de
l'Arménie quand il faut faire
baisser les tensions sur le
terrain.
Nous l'avons démontré quand je me
suis rendue, à la fin du mois
d'avril, sur le terrain, pour
encourager les deux dirigeants à
trouver un accord de paix en
Arménie et en Azerbaïdjan, ainsi
qu'à la frontière, auprès de la
mission d'observation de l'Union
Européenne.
L'existence doit grandement à
notre pays.
Elle joue un rôle utile pour
apaiser les tensions.
Nous sommes enfin aux côtés de
l'Arménie dans le soutien
humanitaire.
Ce sujet a été évoqué lors du
sommet du 1er juin.
La conséquence du blocage illégal
du corridor a aussi été évoquée.
Nous demandons à l'Azerbaïdjan
l'application de cette décision.
Nous sommes aux côtés de l'Arménie
et des Arméniens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Madame Santiago.
- Isabelle Santiago: J'entends
l'action qui est menée.
On est tous mobilisés.
Mais ça fait six mois.
Il s'agit évidemment d'une survie
du peuple.
Il est important de pouvoir le
rappeler à l'occasion de ces
questions au gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Je recevrai, dans les prochaines
semaines, mon homologue de
l'Assemblée nationale arménienne,
qui va venir en visite à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Nous allons lui rappeler notre
soutien.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Yoann
Gillet pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Yoann Gillet: Merci, madame la
présidente.
7 Français sur 10 sont favorables
à un référendum sur la politique
migratoire.
Ils sont 80% à demander de la
matière.
Voici 30 ans que les Français sont
privés de leur droit d'être
consultés sur le sujet.
Les Français n'en peuvent plus, de
cette immigration massive, qui
change le visage de notre pays et
est vecteur d'insécurité.
Ils en ont assez de voir des
demandeurs d'asile et des réfugiés
remplir les pages des journaux
pour des meurtres.
Vous semblez patiner sur ce sujet
majeur.
Ce sujet, s'il avait été pris par
les cornes comme le taureau,
ferait économiser des dizaines de
milliards d'euros par an.
Cela devrait vous intéresser.
Votre gouvernement détient le
record de dettes.
Si vous vous attaquiez enfin à
l'immigration, les Français
pourraient retrouver leur
tranquillité.
Cela devrait guider votre action,
chaque matin.
Votre devoir est de protéger ceux
qui ne peuvent le faire eux-mêmes,
notamment les compatriotes les
plus fragiles.
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir?
Nous avons un projet déjà prêt,
celui de Marine Le Pen.
Nous vous donnons notre accord
pour le copier-coller.
Vous pourriez ainsi vous attaquer
au droit du sol et à la
délinquance, en expulsant les
délinquants étrangers, réformant
le droit d'asile, et l'AME.
Quand allez-vous enfin agir et
nous présenter quelque chose de
solide pour protéger les Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je voudrais faire deux remarques.
La première: je voudrais vous
remercier d'avoir trouvé enfin un
peu de décence.
Je voudrais vous remercier de ne
pas avoir sauté sur votre
téléphone et votre clavier pour
dénoncer je ne sais quel défaut du
fonctionnement du gouvernement
pour pouvoir appuyer vos thèses
fondées sur la peur.
Je veux avoir aujourd'hui quelques
mots pour les événements d'Annecy.
D'ailleurs, les victimes ne vous
intéressent pas!
Vous n'avez pas un mot pour les
enfants!
parents!
Protestations
Comme si, finalement, l'histoire
ne se déroule pas comme imagine
Marine Le Pen et tout le
Rassemblement National.
C'est le dégoût, qui nous inspire,
quand vous parlez de ce sujet.
Deuxièmement: vous parlez de
l'appel au peuple.
Je vous ferai remarquer que madame
Le Pen a déjà été jugée sur son
programme.
Elle a été battue par deux fois
sur son programme présidentiel.
Je veux vous faire remarquer que
le Front National prône
l'adversité depuis plus de 50 ans
et les Français lui disent non à
chaque fois.
Et c'est un grand peuple que le
peuple français!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Antoine
Armand pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Antoine Armand: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Jeudi, un peu avant 10h, à Annecy,
sur le jardin du Pâquier, un homme
est entré dans une aire de jeux et
a poignardé des enfants.
Depuis, nos pensées sont avec ces
enfants.
Nous pensons à eux et aux adultes
blessés.
Tous sont en vie.
Tous sont en vie grâce au
prodigieux rempart d'humanité qui
s'est immédiatement dressé contre
la barbarie!
Ce rempart, il a le visage
d'Henri, des passants et des
agents d'entretien qui se sont
interposés.
Il a le visage des policiers
d'Annecy, des militaires, des
pompiers, du SAMU, de la sécurité
civile.
Il a le visage des soignants
d'Annecy, de Grenoble et de
Genève.
Aujourd'hui, devant la
représentation nationale, nous
leur disons merci.
Applaudissements
- Dès jeudi, vous vous êtes
rendue, avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur, puis le lendemain, le
président de la République est
venu à Annecy et a exprimé la
reconnaissance de toute la nation.
Dimanche, nous nous sommes
rassemblés fraternellement pour
partager cette gratitude.
Elle est plus forte et elle sera
toujours plus forte que les
mensonges et les parades des
récupérateurs sordides et des
opportunistes de la haine.
Mais cette gratitude ne va pas
suffire face aux questions qui
nous hantent.
Nous allons avoir besoin de
réponses.
Nous avons besoin que la justice
fasse son travail.
Pouvez-vous nous communiquer les
derniers éléments de l'enquête?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Nous avons tous été frappés de
stupeur face à l'attaque sauvage
dont ont été victimes des tout
petits enfants, jeudi dernier, à
Annecy.
Nous étions ensemble, monsieur le
député, en effet, quelques heures
après cette attaque, avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur, Gérald
Darmanin.
Mes pensées vont en premier lieu
aux familles de ces petits
enfants, à ces petits enfants,
également, et aux autres victimes
adultes de cette terrible attaque.
Je voudrais à mon tour rendre
hommage et remercier les forces de
l'ordre, la police nationale, la
police municipale, qui sont
intervenues...
Applaudissements
Ces forces de l'ordre ont pu
intervenir minutes après le début
de cette attaque et ont pu
neutraliser cet agresseur.
Je voudrais également rendre
hommage aux forces de secours, qui
ont été en première ligne face à
ce drame absolu, de tout petits
enfants blessés, et qui ont su
prendre en charge ces petits
enfants.
Aujourd'hui, heureusement, leur
vie n'est plus en danger.
Je pense que l'heure est à
l'émotion.
L'enquête doit permettre de faire
toute la lumière sur le parcours
de cet agresseur, toute la lumière
sur ses motivations.
Mais il ne faut pas tout mélanger
et ne pas récupérer des drames
épouvantables comme ceux que nous
avons vécus.
Il faut apporter des réponses à
nos concitoyens, dans la sérénité.
Nous devons plus que jamais les
protéger.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Aurélien
Saintoul du groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Aurélien Saintoul: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame Schiappa, ce n'est pas une
question, que je veux poser à cet
instant.
C'est une supplication que je
formule.
Démissionnez.
Démissionnez, séance tenante.
Permettez de croire un seul
instant que le mot de
"responsabilité" peut avoir du
sens pour un membre du
gouvernement.
La création et l'attribution de
l'argent du fonds Marianne sont
une immense tâche que seule votre
démission peut laver.
Quelle que soit l'hypothèse
retenue, que vous ayez fait preuve
de légèreté, d'incompétence ou
d'un cynisme révoltant, pour
répondre politiquement de vos
actes, il faut démissionner.
Si vous vous obstinez, la Première
ministre doit vous congédier.
Le scandale du fonds Marianne est
proprement inouï et intolérable
dans un régime démocratique.
Vous avez permis et peut-être même
organisé l'instrumentalisation de
l'assassinat ignoble de Samuel
Paty.
Ce crime ignoble voulait mettre à
l'épreuve l'unité de notre peuple.
Vous avez détourné des fonds de
l'Etat pour une campagne
électorale.
Tout confirme ces faits: les
auditions publiques de la
commission d'enquête au Sénat, le
rapport de l'inspection de
l'administration et la démission
de monsieur Gravel.
Tout est lamentable, dans ce
scandale, y compris la tentative
de diversion que vous avez
organisée en posant pour un
magazine de charme.
Comment la honte ne vous a pas
ensevelie?
Comment soutenez-vous encore le
regard de vos pairs du
gouvernement et de la
représentation nationale?
Je vous en adjure, madame
Schiappa, démissionnez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Sonia Backès,
ministre chargée de la
Citoyenneté.
- Sonia Backès: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Visiblement, vous ignorez ce
qu'est l'Etat de droit.
Dans un Etat de droit, c'est la
justice qui juge.
Ce n'est ni le tribunal populaire,
ni les députés.
La justice, vous le savez tous, a
pris en main ce dossier.
La ligne du gouvernement a été
claire depuis le début:
transparence et réactivité.
Avec Gérald Darmanin, nous avons
saisi, dès connaissance des
premières alertes sur le sujet...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
- Sonia Backès: Nous avons saisi,
dès les premières alertes sur ce
sujet, l'inspection générale de
l'administration et la procureure
de la République de Paris sur le
fondement de l'article 40.
Le premier rapport de l'IGA met en
évidence des erreurs, voire même
des défauts sur le suivi
administratif de ce dossier.
L'enquête judiciaire est ouverte.
Il ne nous appartient pas et il ne
vous appartient pas de la
commenter.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Saintoul, nous
ne sommes dupes de rien.
Certains ici se réjouissent de
cette affaire.
Ils l'instrumentalisent à souhait.
Vous aimeriez mettre un terme à la
politique publique de
contre-discours républicain, de
lutte contre les séparatismes, qui
est menée par l'Etat depuis les
vagues d'attentats qui ont marqué
notre pays.
En matière d'islam radical, les
discours les plus violents et les
plus dangereux ne sont plus dans
les mosquées, mais sur les réseaux
sociaux.
Je veux saluer l'action du
secrétariat général du CIPDR.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à Laurent Panifous.
- Laurent Panifous: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
S'il y a bien une préoccupation
majeure et ancienne que nous
entendons tous les jours au coeur
de nos territoires, c'est la
difficulté d'accès aux soins.
Les collectivités se mobilisent
pour y répondre.
La région Occitanie, par exemple,
s'est engagée activement.
Elle a recruté des médecins pour
les territoires sous-dotés.
Un groupe transpartisan s'est
organisé et porte de nombreuses
propositions.
Il y a des lois qui viennent
d'être adaptées.
Aujourd'hui, nous examinons une
autre proposition de loi.
Nous nous réjouissons forcément
que des propositions de loi soient
examinées, même quand elles
constituent des charges pour
l'Etat.
Néanmoins, l'accumulation de ces
initiatives interrogent sur la
cohérence et la stratégie du
gouvernement.
Cela interroge sur les moyens que
vous êtes prêts à investir pour
garantir l'accès aux soins de
tous, sur vos priorités, et sur
l'urgence à agir.
Toutes ces décisions sont
positives et cependant, c'est
encore insuffisant.
Les conditions d'accueil, mais
aussi de travail dans les hôpitaux
et les EHPAD se dégradent.
Les délais de prise en charge
s'allongent.
Les urgences ferment dans trop de
territoires.
Il faut aller plus loin.
On ne peut pas attendre 10 ans que
les prochains médecins arrivent.
Tout n'a pas été fait et tout n'a
pas été essayé.
N'est-il pas temps de s'engager
sur une grande loi santé et
territoires et de faire de la
santé une priorité nationale?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Merci.
La parole est à Agnès Firmin Le
Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Vous l'avez dit, la santé est la
préoccupation numéro 1 de nos
concitoyens.
Le diagnostic, nous le
connaissons.
Il n'existe pas de solution
unique.
Les besoins de santé sont
différents, selon les territoires.
Notre cap est clair et cohérent
depuis 2017.
Il a été rappelé par le président
lors de ses voeux aux personnels
soignants en janvier dernier.
Notre méthode est claire et
pragmatique: avancer avec les
territoires, pour les territoires
et à partir des territoires, avec
les professionnels.
Nous devons mobiliser tous les
leviers à notre disposition.
Nous devons créer des solutions et
les développer pour répondre de
façon concrète à l'accès aux
soins.
J'ai annoncé un plan hier.
Un médecin dans une maison de
santé prend 160 patients par an en
plus et nous allons faire le
dernier kilomètre.
Nous allons élargir les
compétences des professionnels.
Nous allons aussi développer le
partage des compétences.
Et cela, au-delà des 20 nouvelles
mesures.
Nous allons solliciter les
soignants au meilleur de leurs
compétences.
Nous allons fidéliser et valoriser
les professionnels.
Nous allons valoriser les gardes.
Nous allons développer le travail
de nuit.
Nous allons mettre en place la
quatrième année de médecine
générale.
Nous allons nous occuper de la
santé et de la sécurité des
professionnels de santé.
Nous allons avancer sur la
procédure dont nous allons avoir
l'occasion de discuter.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Sophie
Taillé-Polian.
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Merci,
madame la présidente.
.
Après une revalorisation du point
d'indice l'année passée, le
gouvernement annonce désormais une
hausse de 1,7%, alors que
l'inflation dépasse le triple.
Faudra-t-il tabler sur une hausse
négative, l'année prochaine?
On demande aux agents du service
public d'accepter sans broncher
les coupes budgétaires, les
réductions de moyens et les
baisses salariales.
Tout cela est accompagné d'une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail.
Il y a une immense perte de sens
pour les usagers.
Les agents du service public
résistent depuis 20 ans.
Mais vous les avez usés jusqu'à la
corde.
Aujourd'hui, la fonction publique
est désertée.
Vous les faites travailler deux
ans de plus et vous faites
perdurer le sentiment que le
service public n'est pas la
solution.
Notre société n'aurait pas les
moyens de rémunérer correctement
les femmes et les hommes qui
éduquent nos enfants, qui soignent
nos parents, qui gèrent nos rues?
Ceux qui ont neutralisé
l'agresseur d'Annecy ou qui ont
porté secours aux victimes?
On ne pourrait les rémunérer
correctement?
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Vous pourriez le faire, si le
service public avait une valeur à
vos yeux.
Vous allez certainement me
répondre "primes" et autres
pactes, mais le service public a
besoin qu'on croie en lui et que
l'on réinvestisse pour lui dans la
durée.
Toutes ces primes, vous allez les
supprimer et votre trajectoire des
finances publiques ne porte à
croire qu'il n'y aura pas long à
attendre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à Stanislas Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci, madame
la présidente.
La question que vous posez, c'est
la question de la responsabilité.
Est-ce que nous sommes à la
hauteur de nos responsabilités?
Les Français sont concernés par
les questions de pouvoir d'achat.
J'ai toujours pris mes
responsabilités...
Je suis le ministre qui ai le plus
augmenté le point d'indice.
Nous sommes, cette année encore, à
la hauteur de nos responsabilités.
J'ai reçu hier l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et j'ai
pu faire des annonces fortes sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat et
de la rémunération de nos agents
publics.
J'ai annoncé que nous allions
cette année encore mobiliser la
même enveloppe salariale à la
revalorisation des salaires des
fonctionnaires.
Nous allons renouveler cet effort
cette année.
Nous allons faire, très
concrètement, une augmentation de
l'indice fixe des fonctionnaires
de 2,5%.
Ce sera 1,5% de revalorisation du
point d'indice dès juillet.
Nous allons aussi concentrer nos
efforts sur les agents qui ont des
bas salaires et les classes
moyennes de la fonction publique.
J'ai donc ajouté des mesures
spécifiques pour accompagner les
bas salaires et donner de la
progressivité.
Nous allons y consacrer plus de
600 millions d'euros.
J'assume aussi de répondre, dans
l'immédiat, à la question du
pouvoir d'achat, et d'apporter une
prime de pouvoir d'achat aux
agents de la fonction publique les
moins rémunérés.
La moitié des fonctionnaires vont
recevoir, dès septembre, une prime
de 800 euros brut sur leur compte
en banque.
C'est une réponse immédiate aux
questions de pouvoir d'achat.
Vous le voyez, nous prenons nos
responsabilités!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Ma chère collègue?
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Les
fonctionnaires ne sont augmentés
que de 1,5%...
Les loyers augmentent...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à Anne-Cécile
Violland pour le groupe Horizons.
- Anne-Cécile Violland: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
Il y a des événements auxquels
notre mandat nous confronte et
dont nous ne trouvons les mots à
la hauteur de nos émotions.
A Annecy, jeudi dernier, trois
enfants et deux adultes ont été
gravement blessés, sans oublier
les témoins malgré eux de cette
tragédie.
Tout notre soutien leur est
adressé.
Nous avons tous été sidérés et
puis bouleversés.
S'il n'existe aucune explication à
un geste d'une telle atrocité,
l'enquête poursuivant son cours,
il ne faut pas céder à
l'instrumentalisation et à la
démagogie.
Il faut être ferme et juste.
Nous faisons pleinement confiance
à la justice pour permettre aux
familles et aux victimes de se
reconstruire.
De ce drame indicible, il faut se
souvenir de celles et ceux qui
protègent, de celles et ceux qui
sauvent.
Ce sont ces pompiers, ces
médecins, ces infirmiers, ces
policiers et gendarmes, à qui nous
devons tant.
Sans oublier les premiers témoins,
ces héros qui ont tenté de
s'interposer, dont Henri.
Sans la réactivité et le
professionnalisme de ces hommes et
de ces femmes, le bilan aurait été
encore plus tragique.
Aux côté des forces de l'ordre et
des secours, nous devons aussi
soutenir nos maires et nos élus
locaux.
Ils sont aussi les premiers de
cordée au service de notre pays et
de sa protection.
Cette solidarité et cette humanité
font la fierté de notre nation.
Nous leur en sommes immensément
reconnaissants.
Notre action politique doit être à
la hauteur de leur engagement
quotidien.
Comment pouvons-nous accompagner,
monsieur le ministre, nos élus
locaux, pour les aider à faire
face à ces situations d'urgence et
de crise?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Comme l'a dit madame la Première
ministre, à Annecy, l'innommable
est arrivé.
Vous étiez sur place, avec vos
collègues parlementaires, et
monsieur le maire d'Annecy.
Je veux également remercier les
policiers, les policiers
municipaux, les pompiers, mais
aussi le personnel de santé, qui
est intervenu très rapidement, et
qui a permis de sauver la vie de
ces bébés, de ces très jeunes
enfants.
En moins de trois minutes, la
police est intervenue pour
interpeller l'assaillant.
Et quelques secondes ont permis
d'accompagner, les blessés vers
les hôpitaux de Grenoble, de
Genève et d'Annecy.
Vous avez aussi évoqué le travail
très important que nous mettons en
place avec les collègues pour
appuyer les élus locaux.
Je veux vous dire que, dans votre
département, il y a peut-être
quelque chose qui a permis de
faire sauver la vie de ces bébés,
c'est justement le travail en
symbiose entre les pompiers et les
personnels du ministère de la
Santé.
Il y a, dans ce département, une
plate-forme unique.
Quand on appelle le numéro
d'urgence, pour que la régulation
se fasse le plus rapidement
possible entre tous les
personnels...
Je suis heureux de constater que,
malgré ces événements dramatiques,
tous les personnels ont pu
intervenir et sauver la vie de ces
enfants.
J'espère que cela va tous nous
inspirer pour les blancs, pour les
rouges, pour les bleus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Sansu.
- Nicolas Sansu: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, trois
fois plus de médecins généralistes
pour 100.000 habitants sur l'arc
atlantique et sur la Côte d'Azur
que dans les départements dans le
centre de la France.
Les plus grands déserts médicaux
de notre pays sont Mayotte et la
Seine-Saint-Denis.
Des millions de concitoyens vivent
l'absence de médecin traitant
comme une violence, une injustice,
une rupture d'égalité d'accès aux
soins.
C'est le symbole d'une France
humiliée.
Quand les déserts médicaux
avancent, c'est la République qui
recule.
La République recule, c'est la
progression pour la première fois
depuis 1945 de la mortalité
infantile et l'engorgement des
urgences de nos hôpitaux.
La position du gouvernement est
intenable.
Oui, il fallait desserrer le
numerus clausus.
Mais cela ne sera pas suffisant.
L'objectif national des dépenses
de l'assurance-maladie augmente
moins que l'inflation, et ce sera
moins pour la santé demain.
Cela ne sera pas suffisant car
d'ici 2030, le nombre de médecins
généralistes diminuera.
Nous sommes 205 députés issus de
tous les bancs de gauche, de
droite, de centre, qui proposons
un pas vers la régularisation en
permettant l'installation des
médecins dans les territoires qui
en manquent, pour ne pas accentuer
la concentration des
professionnels de santé.
Les députés communistes ont pour
leur part toujours porté le
conventionnement sélectif.
Mais nous savons qu'un petit pas
vaut mieux que 1000 promesses.
Régulation, amélioration de
l'accès aux études de médecine
pour les jeunes issus des classes
modestes, de la réalité comme des
quartiers populaires, facilitation
de l'intégration des médecins
diplômés hors de l'Union
Européenne.
Ecoutez les députés qui portent
des solutions nationales et
locales pour répondre à cette
exigence légitime de nos
concitoyens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député Nicolas Sansu,
il n'existe pas de territoire où
il y aurait trop de médecins.
Je ne peux pas vous laisser dire
ça.
87% de la France est un désert
médical.
La régulation à l'installation est
une idée séduisante en apparence.
Il s'agit en réalité d'une fausse
bonne idée.
Elle est malheureusement inadaptée
à la réalité de notre démographie
médicale.
Elle n'a d'ailleurs été mise en
place par aucun gouvernement, ni
de droite, ni de gauche par le
passé, et pour une bonne et simple
raison: cela ne marche pas.
J'ai eu l'occasion de le dire:
réguler le manque ne résoudra pas
nos problèmes.
Vous qui êtes sur le terrain, vous
le savez.
Je serais curieuse de savoir qui
est prêt à me dire qu'il y a trop
de médecins sur son territoire.
Au contraire, c'est une mesure qui
risque de décourager les étudiants
en médecine, voire de créer une
médecine à deux vitesses en
encourageant le déconventionnement
des médecins, et vous ne le
souhaitez pas.
La responsabilité qui est la
nôtre, c'est de dire à nos
concitoyens qu'il n'y a pas de
baguette magique pour répondre à
l'accès aux soins, mais ce sont de
multiples leviers d'action sur
lesquels le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé.
Ces leviers sont autour de la
formation, de la coopération entre
professionnels.
Beaucoup reste à faire, et soyez
assurés que nous y travaillons
tous les jours.
Nous proposons des solutions
concrètes qui apportent des
résultats tangibles.
La régulation n'apportera rien de
tout cela.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Véronique
Louwagier pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Véronique Louwagier: Suite au
dramatique événement d'Annecy, je
renouvelle mes pensées pour les
victimes et leurs familles.
Je remercie les secours et plus
particulièrement le jeune Henri
pour son courage, et je salue son
sens de l'altruisme et son
civisme.
Les Français peuvent être fiers de
l'héroïsme dont il a fait preuve.
Applaudissements
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Monsieur le ministre, dimanche
matin, à l'appel du collectif Les
soulèvements de la terre, des
militants écologistes ont arraché
près de Nantes des plans de muguet
et des tuyaux qui les irriguaient
pour dénoncer l'utilisation
intensive de l'eau et du sable.
User de violence, détériorer
gratuitement, c'est inacceptable.
Aucun prétexte, aucune cause ne
peut justifier de détruire le
pacte républicain.
Le militantisme est une chose.
Chacun a le droit d'exprimer ses
idées dans le cadre démocratique.
L'activisme destructeur en est une
autre.
Il frappe une profession agricole
qui travaille dur et qui souffre
beaucoup, par ailleurs.
Comment admettre en toute impunité
des appels à la violence, des
appels au sabotage?
Les actes sont signés, revendiqués
et assumés.
Il est d'autant plus urgent d'agir
que les prochains méfaits sont
ouvertement annoncés avec le mode
d'emploi: démanteler des
mégabassines, bétonner les accès
aux vannes, mener des opérations
contre divers sites.
Monsieur le ministre, vous
annonciez il y a quelques semaines
une procédure de dissolution
du groupe Soulèvements de la
terre.
Comment comprendre, alors que
cette association continue à semer
la haine et la violence?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, merci pour
votre question.
Cette association à laquelle vous
fait allusion prétend finalement
aimer la Terre et la servir avec
une forme d'activisme qui lui
appartient.
Quand on aime la Terre, et qu'on
veut la préserver, on développe
les énergies renouvelables, ce que
nous faisons en multipliant par 10
le solaire, et en créant 50 sites
éoliens en haute mer.
On fait le choix du nucléaire.
On fait de la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments, on interdit les
véhicules électriques, on arrête
les locations de passoires
thermiques.
On interdit l'exploitation des
fonds sous-marins à la demande du
président de la République.
Il a obtenu à l'échelle mondiale.
On organise des forums mondiaux...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
- Olivier Véran: Cette association
ne fait rien de cela.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Chers
collègues, s'il vous plaît.
- Olivier Véran: On n'aide pas la
Terre et on n'aime pas la Terre
quand on arrache des salades, du
muguet, et quand on s'en prend aux
agriculteurs.
Pire encore, on n'aime pas la
Terre ni les humains quand on
organise des manifestations
interdites auxquelles on convie
des militants violents pour s'en
prendre aux forces de l'ordre.
Nous partageons votre indignation
et vos marques de soutien à
destination de tous les
agriculteurs.
Nous nous indignons avec vous de
la présence d'élus portant
l'écharpe tricolore sur ces lieux.
Je vous rappelle qu'à la demande
du ministre de l'Intérieur, un
dossier a été monté pour dissoudre
cette association.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Véronique Louwagier: Vous n'avez
répondu que partiellement à ma
question.
La cause écologique est
aujourd'hui encore une fois
dévoyée par ceux qui prétendent la
servir.
L'Etat doit se faire respecter.
L'Etat doit faire respecter la
loi.
Si la loi n'est pas respectée, à
quoi servons-nous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Louis
Boyard, du groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Louis Boyard: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Education nationale,
c'est une bombe sanitaire qui
vient d'exploser avec l'enquête
des journalistes.
Au minimum, 700.000 enfants sont
en danger dans notre pays.
Ils pourraient respirer de
l'amiante dans nos écoles, en
particulier dans les quartiers
populaires et les zones rurales.
Sur près de 20.000 écoles
primaires et maternelles, 30% sont
amiantés.
8 fois sur 10, il y avait de
l'amiante dans les salles de
classe.
Les enfants pourraient développer
un cancer si l'amiante est
respiré.
Il y a urgence.
Nous devons savoir combien
d'élèves, combien de collégiens et
de lycéens, combien de personnes
ont respiré et continueront de
respirer de l'amiante?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Louis Boyard,
comme vous le savez, ce sont les
collectivités qui sont en charge
du bâti scolaire.
Depuis 20 ans, elles sont
également en charge du
désamiantage de leurs équipements
publics.
Néanmoins, le ministère de
l'Education nationale, par
définition, se préoccupe de la
santé et de la sécurité du
personnel et des élèves, et il
veille donc particulièrement à ce
que les procédures à propos du
désamiantage soient suivies.
De manière régulière et en
fonction des risques évalués, les
collectivités doivent transmettre
des informations relatives à la
présence d'amiante dans les locaux
scolaires afin que les chefs
d'établissement puissent prendre
toute mesure nécessaire.
Et c'est notamment vrai pendant
les phases de travaux.
Nous avons également créé en 2019
une cellule qui a publié un guide
à propos du désamiantage, de
manière à informer les usagers et
à informer les collectivités.
Nous sommes conscients d'un
certain nombre de données de santé
publique dont vous faites état.
A ce titre, je suis tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'un partage
d'informations entre le ministère
de l'Education nationale et les
collectivités puisse avoir lieu de
manière à avancer sur cette
question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Louis Boyard?
- Louis Boyard: Comment
pouvez-vous être satisfait de
cette réponse?
Vous parlez, mais rien ne change.
Vous avez la responsabilité de la
sécurité des élèves et des
enseignants.
Vous n'avez pas de chiffres!
Organisez les prélèvements dans
toutes les écoles et publiez les
résultats!
Vous demandez aux mairies de
rénover les écoles, mais elles
n'en ont pas les moyens, vous le
savez.
C'est à l'Etat de créer un fonds
public national pour rénover ses
écoles.
Mais vous ne faites rien de tout
ça.
Vous préférez faire l'autruche,
sacrifier les générations futures
juste pour ne pas payer.
Puisque sur l'amiante, la réponse
de l'Etat,
elle est absente, je me tourne
vers vous, chers collègues.
Dans cette Assemblée, pas un seul
d'entre nous n'est épargné.
Il y a des enfants exposés à
l'amiante dans chacune de nos
circonscriptions.
Au-delà des clivages politiques,
nous avons tout le devoir d'agir.
C'est le devoir de notre Assemblée
que de ne pas sacrifier les
générations futures.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Pap Ndiaye: Monsieur le député,
je viens de vous répondre en vous
indiquant que c'est une question
importante de santé publique et
que nous nous en saisissons.
Ca vaut mieux que votre numéro
habituel de démagogie.
On a besoin de travailler
sérieusement sur cette question.
Nous sommes en lien avec les
collectivités sur cette question,
et je vous prie de croire que nous
y travaillons sérieusement.
Encore une fois, ça vaut mieux que
de la démagogie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
Merci.
La parole est à madame Aude Luquet
pour le groupe Démocrate.
- Aude Luquet: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'agresse à monsieur
Clément Beaune, ministre chargé
des Transports.
La loi d'orientation des mobilités
de 2019 a précisé un objectif de
doublement de la part modale du
transporteur dans les grands pôles
urbains.
Cela a été suivi par un plan de
développement du ferroviaire
inédit d'ici 2040.
Cette semaine, vous avez annoncé
une dotation de 8,6 milliards
d'euros pour les contrats et les
deux tiers de cette enveloppe
iront aux infrastructures
ferroviaires et au transport
public.
Alors qu'il faut inciter les
Français à utiliser des transports
décarbonés, tous les territoires
doivent bénéficier d'un réseau de
transport performant.
Ce réseau doit s'inscrire dans le
respect des usagers, prenant en
compte les contraintes
environnementales.
En Ile-de-France, une étude
d'impact environnemental serait
nécessaire.
Je parle de ma circonscription,
mais le sujet est présent dans nos
territoires.
Vos annonces sur le Lyon-Turin a
besoin d'une réponse de la région.
Il y a aussi le sujet de
Clermont-Paris, nécessaire au
désenclavement de certaines
communes ou agglomérations.
L'Etat et la région vont débuter
des négociations.
Quelle est l'évolution des moyens
consacrés au sein des contrats,
les modalités de mise en oeuvre
des financements et leur
calendrier?
Comment comptez-vous implanter les
critères environnementaux dans ces
projets?
- Clément Beaune: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée Aude Luquet,
vous soulignez l'importance de
notre investissement dans le
domaine des transports, qui est un
enjeu essentiel pour la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens,
pour beaucoup de territoires.
C'est un enjeu central de la
décarbonation.
Les transports représentent 30% de
nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre.
La Première ministre a annoncé un
investissement exceptionnel.
Le plan d'avenir pour les
transports, au mois de février
dernier, que nous sommes en train
de décliner.
Nous avons commencé concrètement
une concertation avec les régions.
La semaine dernière, j'ai annoncé
que les budgets allaient être
significativement augmentés.
C'est une rotation de 50% des
montants annuels que nous
consacrons à cet investissement et
que l'Etat est prêt à porter.
Notamment une priorité au
ferroviaire, au transport public,
au RER métropolitain, et je veux
saluer la proposition de loi qui
sera examinée dans quelques jours
dans cet hémicycle et qui,
j'espère, sera votée pour doter
les outils à nos métropoles, à nos
régions.
Au-delà des contrats, nous devons
continuer un investissement qui
était porté depuis quelques années
dans les trains des territoires.
Je pense au Paris-Clermont qui
fait l'objet d'un programme
d'investissement exceptionnel.
C'est 5 milliards d'euros que
l'Etat est en train d'investir
dans nos trains.
J'étais à Bordeaux et j'y ai
annoncé un effort de
renouvellement de tout le parquet.
L'Etat est au rendez-vous.
Nous attendons les réponses des
régions.
Il y a une plus grande sélectivité
sur les projets routiers, nous
l'assumons, mais certains
investissements inédits sont
portés sur le territoire.
-
La parole est à monsieur Kévin
Mauvieux pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Kévin Mauvieux: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie, des Finances et du
Numérique.
Connaissez-vous le point commun
entre vous et l'Union Européenne?
Votre totale incompétence qui
engraisse la banque et la finance
sur le dos des contribuables.
414%, c'est la hausse en 2022 du
coût de la dette indexée sur
l'inflation, dont vous êtes
responsables, avec la gauche qui
l'a créée, et Les Républicains qui
l'ont perpétrée pendant des
décennies.
14 milliards d'euros sont prévus
rien qu'en intérêt cette année.
300%, vous me direz que les sommes
sont grosses, c'est le coût pour
le plan de relance européen, avec
41 milliards d'euros d'intérêts
prévus au lieu de 15 milliards
seulement.
Par contre, la France n'a perçu
que 37 milliards sur les 40
milliards prévus.
La dette n'est pas un bon vin,
elle n'est pas meilleure parce
qu'elle est plus chère.
On apprend que les 15 milliards
d'euros prévus seront épuisés dès
cet été et que pour couvrir
uniquement l'année prochaine,
Bruxelles recommande aux Etats de
doubler l'enveloppe prévue pour
2024 en la passant de 2 à 4
milliards d'euros.
L'une de vos députés indique qu'il
va falloir créer de nouvelles
ressources propres et qu'il est
"hors de question de baisser les
dépenses du budget européen".
Quelles taxes allez-vous créer
pour financer les charges de dette
qui explosent?
L'Union Européenne ne fera pas
d'efforts.
Quand allez-vous vous attaquer à
notre dette?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal, ministre délégué chargé des
Comptes publics.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Kévin Mauvieux,
je vous avoue que j'étais surpris
en entendant votre question: vous
entendre donner des leçons de
responsabilité budgétaire alors
que dans les débats budgétaires
que nous avons eus depuis un an,
vous n'avez jamais été capable de
proposer une piste d'économie
sérieuse.
En revanche, vous proposez
systématiquement des dépenses
supplémentaires.
C'est un peu difficile d'entendre
des leçons venant de votre part
sur ce sujet.
Mais nous aurons d'autres débats
sur le sujet prochainement.
Pour ce qui est de la trajectoire
et du désendettement, nous avons
présenté il y a quelques semaines
un nouveau programme de stabilité
pour les 5 années à venir, plus
ambitieux que le précédent, et qui
accélère d'un an le désendettement
de la France, qui prévoit aussi un
retour sous les 3% de déficit en
2027 et une diminution de 4 points
de notre charge de dette rapportée
au PIB par rapport au programme de
stabilité.
Une fois qu'on a dit ça, il va
nous falloir réaliser un certain
nombre d'économies.
A chaque fois que nous proposons
des économies, vous n'êtes jamais
au rendez-vous pour nous
accompagner.
En revanche, vous proposez
systématiquement des dépenses
supplémentaires.
Ce qui pose un problème, c'est que
ça va à l'encontre du discours que
vous portez sur la souveraineté et
l'indépendance de notre pays.
Vous voulez condamner notre pays à
rester durablement endetté et donc
soumis aux marchés financiers et à
la dette.
Nous assumons d'agir pour
l'indépendance et la souveraineté
de notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Kévin Mauvieux?
- Kévin Mauvieux: La modestie ne
vous étouffe pas.
Pourtant, vous devriez en prendre
un peu.
Les cadeaux que vous faites aux
banques volontairement par
incompétence permettraient de
financer plusieurs fois la baisse
de TVA, que nous proposons, et une
hausse des salaires avec une
diminution des charges.
Les cadeaux que vous faites aux
banques permettraient de financer
un plan d'envergure pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux.
Les cadeaux que vous faites aux
banques devraient profiter aux
Français.
Avec Marine Le Pen, nous leur
rendrons leur argent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Gabriel Attal: Quels cadeaux?
Vous critiquez en permanence la
contribution de la France à
l'Union Européenne parce que ce
qui vous pose un problème, c'est
l'adhésion de la France à l'UE.
Vous vous cachez derrière des
questions budgétaires, mais vous
voulez la sortie de la France de
l'Union Européenne.
Ca serait la ruine de notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Cécile
Untermaier pour le groupe
Socialiste.
- Cécile Untermaier: Madame la
Première ministre, ce 13 juin, la
question que je vous pose n'est
pas la mienne.
Pour la première fois, des
citoyens de ma circonscription se
sont réunis pour poser au
gouvernement une question
citoyenne.
Ces citoyens qui sont ici, dont je
ne suis aujourd'hui que la
porte-parole, ont retenu plusieurs
thèmes: les déserts médicaux, la
vie chère et le manque
d'enseignants.
Mais c'est la question de la
démocratie, qu'ils ont décidé
d'exprimer ici.
Ils disent continuer à
s'intéresser à la politique, mais
que pour eux, rien n'a changé avec
le grand débat, les conventions
citoyennes et les promesses d'une
démocratie plus représentative.
"Au contraire, nous assistons à
l'utilisation en rafales des
articles 49.3."
Or, la démocratie ne se limite pas
à des procédures
constitutionnelles.
Ce qui la caractérise, c'est la
délibération et la discussion
publique, où s'échangent les
arguments contradictoires.
Ces citoyens considèrent qu'ils ne
pèsent plus sur le cours des
choses et que nous, députés,
sommes ligotés, et notre mandat,
vidé de sens.
Alors c'est pour vous aussi,
madame la Première ministre, que 9
d'entre eux sont ici pour vous
alerter sur le fossé qui se creuse
avec les gouvernants.
Ils vous demandent si vous en avez
conscience.
Pour que la vie politique renoue
avec le "tous ensembles", quelles
mesures concrètes et immédiates
proposez-vous?
Je précise qu'ils vous écoutent.
Ne les décevez pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran, ministre délégué chargé du
Renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Madame Cécile Untermaier, je salue
les 9 citoyens dont vous êtes la
porte-voix et je vous félicite
pour cette initiative
fondamentale.
Bienvenue à tous les citoyens qui
sont en tribune.
Vous écoutez parfois les débats,
interloqués lors des bruits qui
peuvent régner.
En général, ils se font assez vite
une idée de qui sont les pompiers
et qui sont les pyromanes de cet
hémicycle.
Nous traversons une crise de
confiance dans le contexte
politique.
Une crise de confiance qui n'est
pas que politique.
Elle concerne aussi les médias,
qu'on appelle désormais les médias
traditionnels, comme pour mieux
les séparer de ceux qui seraient
les médias non-traditionnels et
qu'on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux.
Une crise de la confiance
scientifique.
Nous l'avons vu pendant le Covid.
Une crise de confiance politique
qui dépasse tous les clivages.
Nous avions siégé sur le même banc
et nous avions fait le même
constat.
Vous êtes ici pour servir
l'intérêt général et non pour
votre intérêt personnel.
Vous savez ô combien vos missions
sont difficiles à l'Assemblée
nationale, comme dans vos
circonscriptions.
Comment repenser les mécanismes
démocratiques?
La convention sur la fin de vie
était un modèle du genre.
Les conventions de la Refondation
animent des milliers
d'établissements scolaires, des
centaines de communautés
soignantes, pour repenser l'école
et la santé de demain.
Le grand débat national montre que
nous sommes en train de chercher
non pas la martingale, mais le
moyen de dire à tous les Français
qu'ils sont utiles et que nous
avons besoin du lien qui nous unit
à vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Madame Cécile Untermaier?
- Cécile Untermaier: Je vous
remercie pour cette réponse.
Simplement vous dire que le chemin
est difficile et que nous aurons
besoin d'être tous ensemble pour
que le débat citoyen vive encore.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, ma
chère collègue.
La parole est à madame Véronique
Riotton pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Véronique Riotton: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
Nous sommes tous encore choqués
par le drame qui s'est déroulé à
Annecy il y a quelques jours, qui
a bouleversé la France et le
monde.
Toutes nos pensées se tournent
vers les victimes et leurs
proches.
Ce drame a eu lieu.
Pour autant, je voudrais saluer
ici la formidable chaîne de
solidarité, de coopération dans la
gestion de ce drame et de ses
conséquences, qui ont pu être
contenues.
Les premiers qui sont intervenus
sont les promeneurs, les lycéens
et les acteurs du tourisme qui
étaient sur place, et qui ont agi
de façon courageuse, soit en
appelant les secours, en faisant
des traductions en langues
étrangères, en faisant un cordon
sanitaire pour éviter que les plus
petits ne soient exposés à ces
scènes si terribles.
Dans un temps record, les
professionnels sont intervenus:
forces de police, pompiers,
soignants, et toute la chaîne de
secours.
Bien sûr, ils sont formés pour
intervenir.
Et le formidable dispositif mis en
place a permis de limiter les
victimes et les blessures.
Pour autant, on n'est jamais
préparé à une telle horreur.
Leur émotion ressentie juste après
témoigne de la fragilité de notre
humanité.
Le temps sera long pour refermer
ces plaies, et il nous faudra
prendre soin de cette population
et je voudrais dire que toutes les
décisions prises ont permis de
sauver les enfants, les adultes,
et de ne faire aucune nouvelle
victime.
Monsieur le ministre, pour ces
héros du quotidien, je souhaite
que la nation leur exprime sa
reconnaissance et gratitude.
Comment, selon vous, pouvons-nous
les honorer de la manière juste et
républicaine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, la parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin, ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la députée Véronique
Riotton, vous avez raison.
C'est le service public et les
femmes et les hommes qui le
composent, quelle que soit leur
mission, qui ont permis de sauver
ces enfants et ces victimes, et
qui ont évité d'en faire
davantage.
Je remercie le préfet et ses
équipes qui ont commandé les
opérations de secours et de
sécurité, mais qui sont aussi
intervenus pour organiser la mise
en sécurité.
Lorsque le préfet arrive et sa
première question, que se pose un
préfet et le ministère de
l'Intérieur, c'est de savoir s'il y
a d'autres personnes dans d'autres
territoires qui peuvent passer à
l'acte.
Malheureusement, la panique bien
légitime se fait démonstration, et
il faut que les services de l'Etat
rassurent.
Monsieur le préfet a su rassurer
tout en menant les opérations de
secours et de sécurité.
L'organisation du ministère de
l'Intérieur a montré la
responsabilité des femmes et des
hommes qui le composent.
En 3 minutes, un équipage de
police est arrivé, puis une équipe
en motos, avant qu'il puisse
continuer sa tuerie terrible, et
ont pu interrompre cette personne.
Un officier de police a utilisé
son arme de service avec grand
professionnalisme.
J'ai proposé au président de la
République des décorations
imaginées pour les prochaines
promotions pour l'ensemble des
personnes qui ont contribué à
sauver ces personnes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Christine
Arrighi.
- Christine Arrighi: Nous avons
appris il y a quelques jours que
l'Arctique pourrait être privé de
banquise dès 2030.
Ce sera 10 ans avant les pires
projections du siècle.
Les événements météorologiques
extrêmes vont se multiplier
partout dans le monde.
Cela va générer un chaos
climatique.
Les scientifiques parlent d'une
élévation du niveau des mers de 6
à 7 mètres.
Ce sont les scientifiques qui
parlent.
188 scientifiques appellent
récemment dans une tribune à
arrêter un projet en Ouganda et
Tanzanie.
Ce projet, ce sont 379 millions de
CO2 supplémentaires dans
l'atmosphère.
Ils viennent se rajouter à tous
ceux déjà produits.
Ce sont aussi des populations
expropriées, des forages au coeur
d'un parc naturel, un risque de
contamination dans le lac...
Le sommet pour un nouveau pacte
financier mondial, organisé à
Paris, les 12 et 23 juin, c'est
une occasion unique de
discussions.
Nous allons en payer tous et
toutes les conséquences.
Quand je dis "payer", c'est dans
tous les sens du terme.
Le système d'assurance mondial est
prévu pour des conjecturels et non
pas structurels.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Merci de saluer l'initiative du
président de la République
d'organiser cette réunion sur ce
sommet de Paris pour avancer sur
un nouveau pacte financier
mondial, qui va nous permettra de
revoir les modalités de
financement climatique et d'ouvrir
une nouvelle voie pour les pays
vulnérables, qui aujourd'hui, ne
peuvent accompagner leur
développement à la vitesse qu'ils
souhaitent, en combinant
développement et solutions du
futur.
Je parle de projets basés sur des
énergies décarbonées et
renouvelables.
Il faudrait investir dans la
décarbonisation des économies.
Il faudrait la sortie du charbon
pour l'Afrique.
Il faut accompagner des projets
créateurs de richesses et
d'emplois pour ces pays.
Il s'agit d'inventer un nouveau
modèle de développement durable
dans ces pays pour qu'ils évitent
de passer par la case
développement durable fondée sur
les énergies fossiles.
Quel est l'objectif du président
de la République?
D'abord, réformer les finances
multilatérales, parce que vous
avez souligné qu'il y a des
difficultés d'accès au financement
multilatéral.
Il y a également la concentration
des subventions et des soutiens
climatiques publics.
Vous savez que la France prend
toute sa part, avec ces milliards
d'euros pour faire émerger de
nouveaux projets.
Il s'agit de 6 milliards d'euros.
Il faut que les financements
privés puissent se diriger vers
ces pays.
Ce sont les objectifs que nous
poursuivons avec le sommet de
Paris.
Il va fixer une feuille de route
que nous allons mettre en oeuvre
derrière, avec la COP28 et les
événements climatiques de cette
année.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Aurélien
Pradié pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Aurélien Pradié: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Que vaut la vie d'une adolescente
de 15 ans?
Humiliée, violée, tabassée,
poignardée 15 fois, le visage
aspergé d'essence et brûlée
vive...
Brûlée vive!
Que vaut, dans notre République,
le martyr de Shaïna?
Son assassin vient être jugé.
Son bourreau a écopé de 18 ans de
réclusion.
30 ans avaient été requis.
Il fera tout au plus 12 ans
derrière les barreaux.
12 petites années de réclusion.
L'excuse de minorité aura sauvé le
bourreau, mais pas Shaïna.
Comment donner l'excuse de
minorité à des actes dont
l'horreur et la préméditation
n'ont plus rien à voir avec ceux
d'un mineur?
Le soir du crime, l'auteur a dit à
ses amis qu'il avait "fumé
Shaïna".
Au procès, il parle d'elle comme
d'une "pute".
Elle a été brûlée vive, enceinte.
Le violeur a retrouvé librement sa
victime et l'a tabassée deux ans
avant son assassinat.
Notre justice ne sait plus
prononcer la perpétuité réelle.
Elle aménage et excuse.
Vous êtes devenus le gouvernement
d'une justice impuissante et
injuste.
Les règles doivent changer.
Si nous oublions Shaïna, nous
serons, vous serez, d'une lâcheté
impardonnable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
J'excuse le garde des Sceaux,
actuellement retenu au Sénat.
Monsieur le député, je partage
votre peine et votre colère.
Notamment, face au drame inhumain
qui a touché la jeune Shaïna et sa
famille.
J'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
son frère et j'ai un immense
respect pour le courage du combat
qu'il mène et pour ses parents.
L'assassin a perdu une part de son
humanité, en commettant cet acte.
Il a tenté
d'affaiblir notre humanité
collective.
Mais nous sommes forts et la
République est forte.
Elle est là pour rendre le
jugement et assurer la protection
des victimes.
Ce qui me gêne, dans votre
interpellation, c'est qu'il existe
la séparation des pouvoirs.
Comme représentant de l'exécutif,
et sans avoir de leçons à vous
donner, comme représentant du
législateur...
Quel que soit ce que peut vous
inspirer la décision qui a été
rendue, elle a été rendue par un
jury populaire représentant la
population, par un jury populaire.
Nous sommes encore dans le délai
qui permet à la famille, si elle
le souhaite, de faire appel.
Donc cette affaire n'est pas
complètement jugée, monsieur le
député.
Vous interrogez le gouvernement
sur ce que nous avons fait.
Vous parlez notamment des
juridictions spécialisées.
Je vous confirme qu'il aura des
pôles spécialisés pour venir en
aide aux victimes et pour juger
les violences et les féminicides.
Personne ne dit que nous sommes
allés au bout de nos démarches.
Mais il y a eu quatre lois, depuis
2017.
Nous avons mis en place les
bracelets électroniques, les
téléphones grands dangers, une
ligne d'écoute 24h/24, nous avons
multiplié par deux le nombre de
condamnations pénales pour les
auteurs de violences.
Ce combat, monsieur le député, il
n'est pas idéologique.
Il ne porte pas une couleur
politique.
Il doit tous nous unir, au sein de
cet hémicycle.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Pradié.
- Aurélien Pradié: Dans le
parcours de Shaïna, il y a des
failles.
Ne pas les voir est irresponsable.
La petite Shaïna a été tabassée.
Dans son parcours, il y a beaucoup
de nos faiblesses.
Ne pas les voir, c'est là, la
véritable lâcheté.
Nous avons le pouvoir d'agir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Stéphane Peu pour
le groupe GDR.
- Stéphane Peu: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Le système éducatif
français reproduit les inégalités
sociales au lieu de les corriger.
Pire, notre système les aggrave.
C'est pourquoi vos déclarations
pour favoriser la mixité scolaire
avait suscité un vif intérêt dans
le pays.
Oui, l'assignation et
l'enfermement des enfants de notre
pays à leur situation sociale
d'origine sont indignes de la
France.
L'excellence éducative se
concentre désormais dans les
coeurs
des métropoles et
les territoires les plus
bourgeois, comme en témoignent les
disparités accablantes des indices
de position sociale entre les
établissements, statistiques que
l'Etat a trop longtemps tenue
secrète.
Il s'agit là d'un véritable
séparatisme qui mine les
fondements de notre République.
Nous en sommes convaincus: un pays
qui laisse les inégalités se
creuser est un pays qui régresse.
Monsieur le ministre, nous ne
voulons pas ouvrir une nouvelle
guerre scolaire, mais nous ne
supportons plus la guerre sociale
dont sont victimes les élèves
issus des milieux populaires.
J'ai donc deux questions.
Premièrement: s'agissant de
l'enseignement privé sous contrat,
quelles suites entendez-vous
donner au rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui s'émeut de l'absence
de contrôle et de contreparties en
termes de mixité sociale, sachant
que 73% de leur financement
provient de l'Etat et des
collectivités?
Deuxièmement: alors que le
département le plus riche de
France hexagonale est mitoyen du
département le plus pauvre,
quelles suites allez-vous donner à
la proposition que vous avez
vous-même jugée "décoiffante", de
réunir dans une même académie,
Paris et la Seine-Saint-Denis?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci.
La parole est à Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Vous avez raison: favoriser la
mixité sociale et scolaire, c'est
améliorer le système scolaire en
général, améliorer le climat
scolaire et social.
C'est même favoriser les principes
de laïcité.
Nous devons donc avancer.
C'est pour ça que nous avons
établi un protocole d'accords avec
le secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique.
Je vais y revenir.
Mais également avec des conseils
départementaux.
Les collectivités ont une
responsabilité éminente, en
particulier en matière de
sectorisation.
Tout dépend des territoires.
Il y a des territoires où il faut
agir avec un certain nombre de
leviers.
On a fixé un objectif: une
amélioration de 20% de la mixité
sociale, en laissant aux recteurs
le soin d'agir sur un certain
nombre de leviers.
En ce qui concerne l'enseignement
privé sous contrat, pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans, un
protocole a été signé, par lequel
l'enseignement privé sous contrat
prend en certain nombre
d'engagements, établit des
relations pérennes avec les
autorités académiques.
Nous avons également des moyens
d'incitation, en attribuant des
postes à des établissements privés
sous contrat, qui feront des
contrats, comme en ouvrant une
classe SEGPA plutôt que dans
d'autres établissements.
Nous avons fait des simulations
sur 10 ans.
Cela prendrait 10 ans.
Nous préférons nous concentrer sur
un tiers des collèges, les plus en
difficulté du département, à peu
près 40, sur lesquels nous allons
investir massivement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
Merci.
La parole est à madame Sophie
Errante pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Sophie Errant: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à Olivier
Véran.
Le site expérimental des
Maraîchers nantais...
Des personnes qui se disent
défenseurs de la planète ont
anéanti une partie de ce travail
essentiel, ce week-end.
Je tiens à apporter tout notre
soutien aux maraîchers victimes de
ces actes insupportables.
Ces actions s'inscrivent dans une
mouvance ancienne, consistant à
considérer les actions directes et
violentes comme
nécessaires pour forcer les
gouvernements à agir.
L'idéologie radicale ne cherche
pas à construire, mais seulement
des lieux d'affrontement.
Un d'entre nous a affirmé qu'il
fallait faire la différence entre
la violence et la dégradation des
biens.
La dégradation des biens d'autrui
est pourtant illégale.
Il faut rappeler le sens et
l'exigence que constitue le port
de l'écharpe tricolore, ici et à
l'extérieur.
Une partie de la population ne
peut pas bafouer l'Etat de droit.
Monsieur le ministre, ces actions
ne peuvent rester impunies.
Mes questions sont simples:
quelles réponses est-il possible
d'apporter à nos concitoyens
victimes de ces actions?
Quel dispositif prévoyez-vous pour
les protéger?
Où en sommes-nous du démantèlement
du collectif les Soulèvements de
la Terre?
Comment peut-on garantir
l'exemplarité attendue dans un
Etat de droit de représentants de
notre nation et de ses élus?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Merci pour votre question.
Le gouvernement partage évidemment
votre indignation, comme ils
partagent l'indignation de votre
collègue qui m'interrogeait sur le
même sujet.
Un soutien évident à l'ensemble
des agriculteurs.
Je pense qu'ils ont regardé
hébétés une serre qui avait été
détruite et des plans de salade
qui ont été arrachés.
Comment on peut défendre la
planète en faisant ça?
Ca veut dire que pour cette
association qui s'est fait appeler
les Soulèvements de la Terre,
l'écologie n'est qu'un prétexte.
Ca rappelle que l'obscurantisme
est une plaie pour l'humanité.
Ca ne fait pas avancer ou
progresser.
Ca ne sert pas la cause
écologique!
Ca ne sert pas la cause agricole!
Voir des élus qui s'associent à
cela, c'est un mauvais combat!
C'est un mauvais combat et une
mauvaise manière de mener ce
combat.
Je le redis volontiers.
Ce qui fait évoluer la cause
écologique, ce sont les réformes
que vous votez et que nous portons
à l'échelle européenne et
internationale.
Il ne faut pas se leurrer.
La France est un pays à l'écoute
de la cause écologique et qui agit
pour cela.
S'ils avaient du courage, ils
feraient leurs actions dans des
pays où l'écologie ne compte pas.
Pour dissoudre une association, il
faut des éléments qui soient
absolument imparables.
Un dossier est en cours d'être
monté pour être présenté devant la
justice en vue d'obtenir la
dissolution de cette association,
comme l'avait expliqué le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Il faut croire en la détermination
du gouvernement pour apporter tout
son soutien aux agriculteurs et à
l'écologie et pour ne jamais
accepter ce type d'exactions du
soi-disant activisme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Meizonnet pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Nicolas Meizonnet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à Bruno Le
Maire.
Novembre 2021: vous avez déclaré
que l'inflation était temporaire.
En août 2022, que nous étions au
pic de l'inflation.
En septembre 2022, que l'inflation
continuait de progresser.
Les archives de vos promesses et
prédictions sont accablantes.
Elles le sont tout autant que vos
bilans.
Vous allez quémander à la grande
distribution quelques efforts.
"Chien qui aboie ne mord pas."
Et vous multipliez les chèques.
Pourtant, ce n'est pas faute de
vous avoir mis en garde: la
politique des chèques, c'est la
politique de l'échec.
Les Français souffrent.
3 millions d'entre eux ont recours
à l'aide alimentaire.
1 français sur 3 vit avec 100
euros à partir du 10 du mois.
C'est la conséquence de votre
obstination à ne pas appliquer les
mesures pérennes que le
Rassemblement National vous
propose depuis des mois.
Il y a notamment la baisse de la
TVA sur l'ensemble des énergies.
Vous avez tenté de disqualifier
ces mesures par le mensonge.
Pourtant, elles portent leurs
fruits.
Au Portugal, l'inflation est à 4%.
Le prix des denrées de base a
baissé.
Le pouvoir d'achat s'est amélioré.
Quand je me regarde, je me désole.
Quand je me compare, je me
console.
Mais avec votre politique, c'est
le contraire.
Ma question est la suivante:
qu'attendez-vous pour faire votre
autocritique et mettre en place
ces mesures pour le bien des
Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Oui, l'inflation alimentaire
baisse enfin au Portugal.
Il faut s'en réjouir, parce que
sur ces débats concernant
l'inflation alimentaire, il faut
être précis: l'inflation au
Portugal était supérieure à 15% sur
un an.
Chez nous, elle n'a franchi ce
seuil qu'en février 2023.
On ne peut jamais répondre...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
Un peu de silence.
- Olivia Grégoire: Au Portugal, en
février dernier, elle était à plus
de 20%.
On va prendre votre proposition:
la baisse de l'inflation
alimentaire est-elle due à la
baisse de la TVA?
On va prendre deux exemples.
En Allemagne, l'inflation
alimentaire a reculé aussi
fortement qu'au Portugal, sans
vraiment toucher à la TVA.
Rien n'a été fait en matière de
TVA.
Ca va bien se passer, monsieur
Tanguy.
L'Espagne a baissé sa TVA.
Mais depuis quand l'inflation
baisse?
Depuis la fin du mois d'avril.
Quand la TVA a-t-elle été
supprimée?
Au mois de décembre.
L'inflation alimentaire a continué
à augmenter pendant quatre mois.
Votre proposition coûterait plus
de 10 milliards d'euros.
Vous campez sur votre seule
proposition.
Nous n'avons toujours aucune
garantie qu'elle servirait la
baisse des prix pour les
consommateurs.
Nous agissons avec les
distributeurs, avec les
industriels.
Les baisses de prix sont en cours.
Pendant que certains pérorent,
notamment sur ces bancs, les
industriels sont en train de
négocier.
Les baisses vont aller entre 5 et
20%.
Il a toujours ceux qui causent et
ceux qui font.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Vincent
Thiébaut.
- Vincent Thiébaut: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Je suis interpellé quasiment toute
la semaine par les parents
d'élèves sur la problématique du
non-remplacement des professeurs
absents.
Cette situation est dramatique.
Nous devons faire face à une
situation inquiétante et urgente,
aujourd'hui.
Elle a des conséquences
dramatiques et vous les
connaissez.
Ce sont des élèves qui se
retrouvent dans des classes
surchargées ou qui n'ont plus
cours que deux jours par semaine
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire.
Les parents sont obligés de
s'absenter de leur travail pour
pouvoir garder les élèves.
Il y a des témoignages
inquiétants.
Une maman a dû démissionner à
cause des absences non-remplacées.
Le 26 mai, un collectif qui
regroupe 18 associations de
parents d'élèves et d'enseignants
a tenu une conférence de presse à
Strasbourg pour alerter sur ce
sujet.
Ils ont mis en place un système de
QR codes pour signaler les
situations inquiétantes.
87 alertes ont été remontées
depuis le mois de février.
La Première ministre a annoncé
vouloir changer les choses
concernant la question des
professeurs absents.
Nous devons prendre cette question
à bras-le-corps.
Il en va de l'avenir de notre
système éducatif, mais avant tout
de l'avenir de nos enfants.
Monsieur le ministre, au vu de ces
situations, envisagez-vous un
véritable fléchage ministériel?
Quelles sont vos plans pour la
rentrée prochaine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Je vous remercie, mon cher
collègue.
La parole est à Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
La question que vous posez est
importante et soulève celle de la
continuité du service public de
l'éducation.
Nous y répondons d'une double
manière.
C'est celle des remplacements
non-assurés.
Plusieurs milliers d'heure sont
perdues chaque année.
C'est un fait incontestable.
D'abord, à partir de la rentrée,
la mise en place
d'un pacte, avec de nouvelles
missions, parmi lesquelles les
démissions de remplacements de
courte durée.
Cela se fait déjà dans un certain
nombre d'établissements.
Les trous dans les emplois du
temps vont ainsi disparaître.
Nous sommes très confiants sur le
démarrage rapide de ce pacte à
partir du 1er septembre.
La deuxième réponse, c'est celle
de l'attractivité du métier.
A la fin de chaque année
budgétaire, nous rendons plusieurs
milliers de postes que nous
n'avons pas pu pourvoir.
La question n'est pas forcément
celle d'augmenter des postes que
nous allons rendre à la fin de
l'année, mais celle de pourvoir
des postes, notamment dans
certaines académies pour le
premier degré, et dans certaines
disciplines, pour le second degré.
C'est pour cela que nous faisons,
le gouvernement, la Première
ministre et le président de la
République, un effort budgétaire
considérable pour augmenter la
rémunération des enseignants, avec
des augmentations qui iront de 7,8
à 11,3% pour les 15 premières
années.
S'ajoutent alors les missions qui
sont aussi rémunérées.
Nous avons aussi à travailler sur
les carrières.
Nous avons aussi à répondre sur la
question sociale de la place que
nous souhaitons donner aux
professeurs dans notre pays.
Je souhaite que cette place soit
revalorisée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Yves
Bony pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Jean-Yves Bony: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la
Souveraineté alimentaire, est-ce
que la France veut encore de ses
vaches et de ses prairies que ses
animaux pâturent ou
préfère-t-elle miser sur les races
brésiliennes pour remplir les
assiettes de nos concitoyens?
La question mérite d'être posée,
tellement nos éleveurs sont
régulièrement mis au banc des
accusés.
Même la Cour des comptes s'en est
mêlée.
Le Cantal est le département le
moins pollué de France!
Même avec ses vaches!
Aujourd'hui, les éleveurs luttent
pour leur survie.
En 60 ans, la France a perdu 3
millions de vaches et cette
dynamique terrifiante s'accélère.
La perte s'élève à 1 million sur
ces dernières années.
2000 éleveurs ont quitté leur
activité.
La conséquence directe est un pic
des importations et la perte de
notre souveraineté alimentaire.
Près de 30% de la viande bovine
que nous consommons est importée
de pays dont les éleveurs n'ont
pas façonné le paysage et n'ont
pas contribué à l'amélioration de
nos villages.
Pour toutes ces raisons, ces
provocations faites au monde
agricole, accepteriez-vous de
travailler à un plan de relance de
la filière?
Allez-vous exclure la viande
bovine de ces renégociations
internationales?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, cher
collègue.
Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Il y a des réponses qui doivent
commencer par la conclusion.
Je vais commencer par la
conclusion.
Vous serez fixés sur l'intention
du gouvernement.
Vive l'élevage et vive
l'agriculture française!
C'est dit.
Certaines données me semblent être
omises.
Les agriculteurs nous font manger.
Donc ils nous font vivre.
Donc nous avons besoin d'eux.
Il faut leur dire que nous les
aimons.
On les aime parce que
l'agriculture, c'est bon pour la
planète et pour l'écologie.
J'ai quelques chiffres.
Un hectare de prairie permanente,
c'est 110 kg de CO2 absorbés
chaque année.
Les prairies stockent 8 millions
de CO2 chaque année dans notre
pays.
L'élevage produit des engrais...
Pourquoi vous criez alors que nous
sommes d'accord?
Ce n'est pas contre moi?
D'accord.
Allez-y, alors.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Ca vous passe
au-dessus, monsieur le ministre!
- Olivier Véran: Je me fais le
défenseur de l'opposition de
gauche.
Il faut que ça s'arrête.
L'élevage produit des engrais
organiques qui sont nécessaires à
l'agriculture biologique.
Il permet aussi la lutte contre
les incendies.
Nous l'avons vu l'été dernier.
Il y a des mots d'amour, mais il y
a des preuves d'amour.
Comptez sur le ministre de
l'Agriculture, qui se trouve
actuellement en Suède, pour redire
aux agriculteurs la conclusion:
vive l'élevage et vive
l'agriculture française!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Ludovic
Mendes
- Ludovic Mendes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Transports.
La région Grand Est a des attentes
particulières sur les mobilités,
et notamment dans la Moselle.
Chaque jour, ce sont plus de
100.000 Français qui partent
travailler au Luxembourg avec des
enjeux de mobilités au coeur du
quotidien.
Ces mêmes milliers de Français se
retrouvent entassés dans un train
supprimé ou en retard, ou sont
bloqués pendant des heures dans
leur voiture pour faire 50 km sur
un axe routier surchargé.
Ces problématiques démontrent que
nous vivons sur un territoire
dynamique qui doit prévoir son
avenir sereinement.
Le maintien du développement de
l'aéroport et de la gare à
quelques kilomètres l'un de
l'autre au coeur de ma
circonscription sont essentiels.
Tout comme la lésion ferroviaire
nord-sud ainsi que le transport
fluvial et le plus grand port
céréalier de France.
Une région comme la nôtre au coeur
de l'Europe et qui concerne tous
les échanges a besoin d'annonces
fortes pour son avenir
touristique, écologique et
économique.
Ces annonces doivent être en lien
avec le changement climatique pour
permettre le transport décarboné
et les plates-formes multimodales.
Vous nous annoncez un
investissement de plus de 8
milliards d'euros, soit une
augmentation de plus de 50% par
rapport à la période précédente,
et 650 millions d'euros dans le
cadre des plans contrats régions.
Le développement de notre
territoire par la mobilité
garantit le développement
économique, favorisant le lien
social et l'accessibilité.
La mobilité pour tous doit
répondre aux besoins de tous,
concernant les personnes en
situation de handicap.
Nous vous remercions de ces
efforts considérables.
Pouvez-vous nous détailler le plan
pour les transports, et plus
particulièrement pour la région
Grand Est?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Monsieur le
député, votre question me donne
l'occasion de revenir brièvement
sur les enjeux de ce plan d'avenir
pour les transports, son contenu
inédit en matière
d'investissements que porte
l'Etat, et les contrats plan
région que nous avons signés la
semaine dernière.
Pour l'ensemble du pays, c'est un
effort sans précédent.
8,6 milliards d'euros, c'est 50%
de plus que la génération
précédente.
C'est 60% de l'enveloppe pour le
ferroviaire.
Les transports décarbonés n'ont
jamais été portés à cette ampleur
et à ce niveau.
Nous faisons le choix de doubler
les montants absolus que nous
consacrons au ferroviaire et au
transport public.
L'engagement est très clair, et il
ne peut plus y avoir de doute sur
l'engagement de ce plan, annoncé
en février par la Première
ministre.
Pour la région Grand Est, vous
connaissez mon attachement aux
enjeux de transport et de
mobilités.
Nous avons des projets à discuter
avec la région.
Je crois pouvoir dire que le
président de la région est ouvert
à cette discussion.
Je crois qu'il est satisfait de
l'engagement de l'Etat, et dans
les prochaines semaines, nous
pourrons conclure avec lui ce
contrat.
Il portera des engagements majeurs
pour développer le transport et
décongestionner les axes routiers.
Nous aurons des discussions sur
les liaisons transfrontalières de
manière générale, et je suis
engagé pour qu'ensemble, nous
trouvions des solutions sur
d'autres projets précis comme la
liaison Nancy-Lyon, qui est chère
à votre coeur.
Nous trouverons des solutions pour
établir cette liaison essentielle.
- Ludovic Mendes: Merci pour cette
réponse.
Le milieu économique vous attend.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Delogu pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Sébastien Delogu: Ce matin, une
tribune inédite portée par le
collectif des familles de victimes
et une cinquantaine d'associations
marseillaises a été publiée dans
Mediapart étant soutenue par plus
de 200 parlementaires et une
dizaine de maires.
Elle appelle à une réponse
politique globale.
Les semaines et les mois passent
et les fusillades et les
assassinats se multiplient à
Marseille et partout en France.
Ces meurtres sont l'arbre qui
cache une forêt de conséquences
beaucoup plus systémiques, et
votre gouvernement ne semble pas
vouloir s'y attaquer.
La misère et la précarité des
habitants de nos quartiers,
l'accès au droit de plus en plus
difficile car les services publics
ferment, ce sont des générations
entières qui naissent et qui
grandissent à l'écart de l'égalité
républicaine.
A l'abandon généralisé s'ajoutent
un discours raciste, plein de
mépris et de haine.
A l'Assemblée nationale, on ne
parle jamais de leur avenir, sauf
pour les salir à travers des
discours qui visent à les rendre
coupables, à rendre coupables
celles et ceux qui sont en fait
les principales victimes de cette
situation.
Dans nos quartiers, on ne refuse
pas la République.
Ils apportent chaque jour des
actions de tout horizon face à un
Etat depuis trop longtemps
démissionnaire.
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin, j'espère
que l'inefficacité des mesures que
vous avez mises en place vous
amène aujourd'hui à un peu plus
d'humilité.
Vous qui n'avez eu aucun mot pour
ces morts, qu'attendez-vous pour
rétablir l'égalité républicaine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Sébastien
Delogu, on peut se rejoindre sur
beaucoup de vos constats.
Vous êtes élu des quartiers
populaires.
Vous êtes issu des quartiers
Je suis élu des quartiers
populaires et je suis issu des
quartiers populaires.
Vous avez...
Vous avez parfaitement raison.
A la base de tout, il y a
l'égalité républicaine, l'accès au
logement, à l'école, à la santé,
et à l'éducation.
Je ne peux que vous rejoindre dans
ce combat républicain qui explique
parfois des dérives qui ne sont
pas excusables, mais qui
justifient l'action beaucoup plus
puissante que peuvent faire la
République et la France pour
sauver ces enfants de la
République.
Il y a l'action du ministère de
l'Intérieur, qui traite les
conséquences: la lutte contre la
drogue.
A Marseille, il y a beaucoup de
drogue, beaucoup d'activité des
services de police, et il y a des
fusillades qui déciment des
familles entières.
Il y a deux clans à Marseille, et
la police judiciaire travaille
là-dessus.
Et il y a tout ce qu'on fait en
amont.
Le président de la République se
rendra bientôt à Marseille.
Vous aurez sans doute une
discussion avec lui.
Il y a des efforts sans précédent.
Marseille en a besoin pour sauver
les enfants et je voudrais vous
remercier.
Je vous ai encouragé à aller voir
les services de police et vous
l'avez fait.
Vous avez rencontré la préfète de
police, les CRS, les policiers de
la BAC.
Je pense que vous avez vu la
difficulté de leur métier.
Vous m'avez demandé de rencontrer
les collectifs et je le ferai
quand je viendrai avec le
président de la République à
Marseille, quand vous m'inviterez
dans cette jolie ville.
Il n'y a pas ici ou là une si
grande différence d'appréciation.
- Merci, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno
Millienne pour le groupe
Démocrate.
- Bruno Millienne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre du Travail.
La réforme des retraites est
pleinement engagée par les
services de l'Etat, avec la sortie
des premiers décrets.
Cette réforme permettra de
remettre plus de justice sociale
dans notre régime de retraite en
revalorisant les plus petites
retraites et en réduisant le
nombre d'années de cotisations
pour les carrières longues.
Le débat public sur cette réforme
a trop souvent été pollué par des
désinformations et des raccourcis
qui ont pu être induits, si bien
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui en demande
d'une information claire et fiable
sur le sujet, comme le montre la
saturation du simulateur de
retraite mise à jour hier.
Cette information claire et
fiable, c'est aussi et surtout
auprès des personnels de la Caisse
Nationale d'Assurance Vieillesse,
que nous la trouverons dans les
prochains mois.
Je prends l'exemple de mon
département des Yvelines, où les
effectifs sont passés de 41 à 26
collaborateurs au cours des 10
dernières années: je comprends
parfaitement et soutient votre
volonté de rendre plus efficient
les services publics.
Un grand nombre de ces évolutions
passent notamment par la
digitalisation et l'automatisation
de certaines tâches pour permettre
aux agents de se concentrer sur
les dossiers les plus complexes.
Je connais également votre
attachement pour les conditions de
travail des agents publics.
Face aux inquiétudes légitimes des
personnels, j'aimerais savoir si
un plan est prévu pour faire face
à cela sur le plus long terme?
Quelles sont les garanties que
vous pouvez apporter aux
personnels quant au maintien des
bonnes conditions de travail?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député Millienne, vous
interrogez le gouvernement sur
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
des retraites, ainsi que les
moyens qui y sont mis.
Je vous prie d'excuser le ministre
du Travail qui est en déplacement
et qui n'a donc pas pu être avec
nous.
L'ensemble des services de l'Etat
et des caisses de retraite sont
pleinement engagés dans ce
chantier.
Nous sommes au rendez-vous de
l'application de la réforme pour
qu'elle soit mise en oeuvre dès le
1er septembre.
Vous l'avez rappelé, les premiers
décrets ont été publiés il y a 10
jours, maintenant.
C'est désormais l'écriture
d'autres décrets qui est en cours.
Ceux des régimes spéciaux, de la
pénibilité, des petites pensions,
mais aussi de la transition vers
la retraite.
Ce sont aussi de nouveaux droits
que nous construisons pour nos
concitoyens.
Ce chantier mobilise tout
particulièrement la Caisse
Nationale d'Assurance Vieillesse,
qui bénéficie pour cela de moyens
supplémentaires.
Sans attendre le déploiement de la
réforme, nous avons anticipé cette
question et nous avons permis à la
caisse de recruter déjà plus de
200 nouveaux collaborateurs.
Nous avons également souhaité
accompagner cette transformation
en confortant des moyens pour les
5 prochaines années dans le cadre
d'une convention d'objectifs et de
moyens, qui leur donne la
visibilité nécessaire sur les
moyens qu'ils peuvent engager dans
la durée.
Cette convention vient d'être
adoptée en conseil
d'administration de la Caisse
Nationale d'Assurance Vieillesse
et elle est désormais signée.
Elle prévoit notamment un maintien
des effectifs et le renforcement
de 400 CDI supplémentaires en 2024
ainsi que le recours à plus de 600
CDD.
Dans la région Ile-de-France, la
caisse compte près de 2500 experts
engagés, 25 agences de proximité,
et surtout 160 maisons France
Services.
La totalité de la population
francilienne se situe donc à moins
de 30 minutes des services de la
Caisse Nationale d'Assurance
Vieillesse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Stéphane Lenormand pour
le groupe LIOT.
- Stéphane Lenormand: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Education
nationale et fait suite à un
certain nombre de questionnements
que j'ai.
L'inclusion scolaire est érigée au
rang de priorité.
Mais est-ce vraiment le cas au
regard du statu quo sur la
situation des accompagnants des
élèves en situation de handicap ou
aux besoins spécifiques?
Ils sont de nouveaux en grève et
nous alertent sur la précarité de
leur métier, pourtant essentiel.
Les avancées se font au
compte-gouttes.
Vous aviez à une époque parlé de
prise en compte du temps
périscolaire.
C'est un vrai sujet.
Notre coprésidente avait
d'ailleurs déposé une proposition
de loi en ce sens.
Le problème est important et les
questions centrales sont toujours
sans réponse.
Je pense au temps de travail
réellement effectué en dehors du
temps avec les élèves: formations,
travail avec les équipes
pédagogiques, préparation, ou
encore la réalisation du temps de
travail qui n'est pas encore
satisfaisante.
Certains sont contraints de
jongler avec plusieurs
établissements.
Enfin, nous devons donner de
vraies perspectives de carrière
aux AESH.
Cela implique d'améliorer
l'information, mais aussi de
valoriser leurs acquis.
Nous sommes encore bien loin de la
juste reconnaissance du métier
d'AESH.
La question de la titularisation
doit pouvoir être étudiée sans
tabou: rémunération, temps de
travail, conditions de travail et
formation.
Ces quatre enjeux ne doivent plus
être traités de manière séparée.
Pensez-vous que l'école puisse
être réellement inclusive sans
véritable statut?
Pour nous, ce statut est
indispensable, à la fois pour les
personnels que pour les élèves
accompagnés.
Sur ce sujet, il y a eu beaucoup
d'annonces.
J'aimerais avoir aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye, ministre de l'Education
nationale et de la Jeunesse.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Lenormand, la
situation économique d'AESH est
déterminante pour la qualité de la
scolarisation des élèves en
situation de handicap.
Je partage les questions que vous
posez.
Nous avons ces derniers temps fait
trois avancées très importantes.
Premièrement, la loi de finances
2023 prévoit une augmentation
salariale nette de 10% au 1er
septembre de 10% au 1er septembre
2023.
C'était d'ailleurs un amendement
qui était porté par les groupes
Renaissance, MoDem et Horizons.
C'est une enveloppe supplémentaire
de 80 millions d'euros pour cette
année 2023.
Deuxièmement, cette revalorisation
s'ajoute au primes Rep+ qui sont
valables pour les AESH depuis le
1er janvier dernier.
Et enfin, après le vote définitif
de la loi Victory, ils pourront
bénéficier d'un CDI au bout de 3
ans et non au bout de 6 ans, avec
la construction d'une carrière.
Par ailleurs, dans le cadre de la
conférence nationale du handicap,
le président de la République a
annoncé un certain nombre
d'avancées qui concernent
également les AESH.
Cela passe également par le fait
de tendre vers les 35 heures.
Nous le faisons avec les
collectivités territoriales en
signant des conventions qui
permettent que l'Etat soit
employeur unique.
Il faut 35 heures avec un temps
scolaire et un temps périscolaire.
Ce sont les collectivités qui
remboursent le temps périscolaire.
Nous souhaitons leur proposer des
missions, notamment en lien avec
la vie scolaire, pour que la
situation d'AESH s'améliore.
60, ce n'est pas suffisant pour la
formation.
Nous voulons améliorer et
progresser ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Julien
Rancoule pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Julien Rancoule: Merci, madame
la ministre.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Dans un an, la France aura
l'honneur d'accueillir les Jeux
Olympiques pour la 3e fois de son
histoire.
Dans le même temps, le défi de la
sécurité privée n'a jamais semblé
si difficile à relever.
25.000 agents de sécurité privée
doivent encore être recrutés.
Selon la Fédération nationale de
la sécurité privée, la filière
déplore déjà un déficit structurel
de 20.000 agents au quotidien.
Les sociétés préféreront toujours
assurer des prestations pour leurs
clients réguliers plutôt qu'un
contrat de quelques semaines pour
les Jeux Olympiques.
La preuve, les appels d'offre ne
sont pas tous pourvus.
Où en est le continuum de
sécurité?
Plutôt que d'avoir une vision à
long terme pour la profession,
vous avez créé une carte
professionnelle "surveillance
grand événement".
Qui va passer une formation de 106
heures valable un an pour
travailler deux semaines?
Croyez-vous que cela va permettre
de recruter les 25.000 agents
vacants?
Madame la ministre des Sports,
vous cherchez des agents de
sécurité privée dans les pays
francophones.
Quelle méconnaissance totale du
sujet...
On sait qu'ils sont payés 50% plus
en Belgique.
Et je ne vous parle pas de la
Suisse.
Alors que les professionnels
considèrent déjà qu'il est trop
tard sur le sujet, comment trouver
les 25.000 agents de sécurité dont
la France a réellement besoin pour
encadrer les Jeux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, je veux
d'abord m'associer à la
reconnaissance légitime que nous
avons pour les agents de sécurité
privée.
Ils font un travail difficile,
essentiel, est important.
Permettez-moi d'être interrogatif
par rapport à votre question.
Si nous avons plus de mal à
recruter des agents de sécurité
privée, si nous avons de nouvelles
cartes, c'est parce que nous
sommes plus exigeants.
J'aimerais connaître la position
du Rassemblement National quand le
gouvernement a décidé de ne plus
mettre des personnes qui ne
parlent pas français, qui doivent
passer par tous les services de
renseignement pour qu'on puisse
valider leur engagement
professionnel, et par ailleurs,
qui doivent être là depuis plus de
5 ans sur le territoire national.
Etes-vous d'accord avec ces
mesures que nous avons prises?
Est-ce que vous acceptez que nous
puissions être plus exigeants?
Il se pourrait, monsieur le
député...
La parole est libre, je sais que
vous n'avez pas souvent l'occasion
de répondre à vos arguments
démagogiques.
Il se pourrait que vous soyez à la
fois pyromane et pompier,
souhaitant avoir plus d'exigences
avec le secteur, et en même temps,
nous reprocher d'employer des gens
sur le secteur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Mon cher collègue, allez-y.
- Julien Rancoule: Vous répondez
encore une fois à côté.
Vous manquez d'agents de sécurité
parce que vous avez des dizaines
d'agents de sécurité qui sont
détenteurs de la carte
professionnelle et qui quittent la
profession parce que le métier est
dévalorisé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous n'apportez
pas de proposition.
Vous ne répondez jamais à aucune
responsabilité.
La vérité, c'est que nous
travaillons à l'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques avec l'ensemble
des agents de sécurité.
Les augmentations de salaire par
branche, c'est une première.
Nous encourageons les entreprises
à mieux payer leurs salariés.
Soyez du côté des ouvriers de la
sécurité, moins du côté des
patrons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole...
S'il vous plaît.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Alauzet pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Eric Alauzet: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Fonction
publique, Stanislas Guerini.
Les fonctionnaires, comme
l'ensemble des Français, sont
confrontés à une érosion de leur
pouvoir d'achat et de leur
reste-à-vivre en raison de
l'inflation galopante, apparue
avec la reprise économique
post-Covid puis la guerre en
Ukraine.
Cette inflation, en particulier
sur les produits alimentaires,
pèse sur les salaires les plus bas
et précarise certains ménages qui
peinent à joindre les deux bouts.
Le gouvernement a annoncé une
hausse de rémunération en faveur
des plus modestes, et le SMIC se
réduit.
Ainsi, les hausses générales
seront complétées par des
attributions de points d'indice
plus favorables aux bas salaires.
Des hausses qu'il convient
d'apprécier, non pas seulement sur
la base de l'augmentation
générale, mais en prenant en
compte les catégories B et C.
Il faut se départir de la mauvaise
foi.
Au total, ce ne sont pas moins de
3,5 milliards d'euros qui seront
engagés dès cette année, et 6
milliards d'euros l'année
prochaine pour revaloriser les
salaires de nos fonctionnaires
après les 7,5 milliards de 2022.
Pourriez-vous nous détailler
l'ensemble des mesures que vous
avez annoncées aux partenaires
sociaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Stanislas
Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, vous avez
raison de souligner que
l'inflation est en train de
décélérer.
Elle est la plus faible d'Europe.
Le gouvernement s'engage à
contenir cette inflation.
Elle reste forte.
En particulier sur l'alimentaire.
Elle a des conséquences très
concrètes.
Elle touche de plein fouet les
plus bas niveaux de rémunération,
dans le privé et dans le public.
Elle entraîne une dynamique sur le
salaire minimum, que nous ajustons
systématiquement dans la fonction
publique.
Il y a des conséquences concrètes.
Parfois, il y a un effet de
non-progressivité des carrières,
d'écrasement des grilles.
Nous avons pris nos
responsabilités dans la
concertation.
J'ai réuni l'ensemble des
associations d'élus dans le
dialogue social, avec les
organisations syndicales.
Nous avons assumé de mettre les
moyens importants, 3,5 milliards
d'euros sur le deuxième semestre,
6 milliards en année pleine, et de
concentrer ces moyens sur les plus
bas niveaux de rémunération.
C'est ce que nous faisons quand
nous versons des points d'indices
sur les débuts de catégorie pour
redonner de la progressivité aux
carrières.
J'assume de débloquer une prime de
pouvoir d'achat pour l'ensemble
des agents qui seront rémunérés et
qui sont rémunérés en dessous de
3250 euros brut.
Le pouvoir d'achat, ce sont des
mesures salariales.
J'en viens de faire la
démonstration.
Ce sont aussi des démonstrations
concrètes.
Quand nous décidons de revaloriser
la prise en charge des transports
en commun, cela a des conséquences
très concrètes dans le
portefeuille.
Pour un agent francilien, son pass
Navigo est remboursé à 70%.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Eric Alauzet: Merci pour cette
question.
Nous pouvons comprendre que les
Français demandent plus et
espèrent plus, mais il faut aussi
saluer les efforts qui sont faits.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Elise
Leboucher pour La France
Insoumise.
- Elise Leboucher: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé,
à Saint-Nazaire, une unité pour
adolescents et une unité
d'admission sont fermées.
A Rennes, Marseille, Draguignan...
La liste est trop longue.
42, c'est le nombre de lits qui
ont fermé à l'hôpital psy en
Sarthe.
18 ans de bons et loyaux services,
l'accueil inconditionnel, l'asile
aux plus vulnérables, la
réflexion...
Autant de choses devenues
indésirables dans nos hôpitaux.
Le turnover, le flux de patients,
voilà de quoi nous parlons
maintenant.
Monsieur le ministre, il n'y a pas
que les soignants et les médecins
qui tirent la sonnette d'alarme
pour la Cour des comptes, dont on
ne peut pas dire qu'elle soit
insoumise.
On constate un manque de volonté
politique dans les moyens
attribués à la psychiatrie elle a
la
pédopsychiatrie.
Comment sortir de cet état de
crise permanent, et surtout,
comment soigner avec humanité?
Il y a des conséquences terribles
pour des milliers de gens qui
n'arrivent plus à supporter le
quotidien terrible.
La situation de détresse que vous
provoquez en psychiatrie est
symptomatique.
Les conséquences de vos mauvais
choix politiques font reculer
l'accès aux soins et les prises en
charge.
Depuis la tarification à l'acte,
vous avez imposé l'idéologie
néolibérale dans notre système de
santé contre l'avis de la
communauté soignante.
Vous avez transformé le soin en
marchandises pour vos amis les
plus riches en maltraitance pour
les soignants.
Aurez-vous le courage de rendre à
la Sarthe ces 42 lits?
De porter un réel plan d'urgence
pour la psychiatrie?
Si vous ne le souhaitez pas,
passez la main.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Firmin Le Bodo.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Madame la députée, je tiens à
réaffirmer l'importance que nous
accordons à la santé mentale et la
psychiatrie.
C'est un enjeu majeur que nous
défendons.
Je n'ignore pas le climat
d'inquiétude face aux difficultés
auxquelles font face les services
psychiatriques, particulièrement
dans le secteur public.
La crise sanitaire a mis en avant
cet enjeu, notamment chez les plus
jeunes.
Je sais que cet enjeu a pu être
mis en lumière dans le contexte de
drame récent, et parfois
instrumentalisé.
Je tiens à vous rassurer.
Le gouvernement est mobilisé sur
le sujet.
Depuis 2018, nous avons engagé une
feuille de route ambitieuse.
Ce sont près de 50 mesures qui
sont déployées sous la supervision
du délégué ministériel.
Nous avons fait un bilan d'étape
de la feuille de route en mars
dernier devant les acteurs
concernés.
Les choses avancent sans nier les
difficultés: développement de la
prévention, développement des
compétences psychosociales à
l'école, développement de la
prévention du suicide, ou encore
le dispositif de vigilance,
amélioration de la prise en charge
de près de 90.000 patients à
300.000 consultations, dont 20% de
mineurs, renforcement des centres
médicaux psychologiques et de
maisons des adolescents dans tout
le département, allongement de la
formation en psychiatrie et
augmentation des postes en
pédopsychiatrie, ou encore travaux
des assises de l'enfant.
Ce n'est pas encore suffisant et
beaucoup reste à faire.
Nous nous y employons activement.
La santé mentale doit être
reconnue comme indissociable de la
santé globale.
La santé mentale sera prise en
compte de manière renforcée dans
les bilans de prévention et dans
la prochaine stratégie nationale
de santé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
suspendue.